πρέπει να έχει και μια σχέση με αυτόν τον τομε νομίζω όπως είναι επερβολικόν το
τοότιδε γίννται ελάθει και ελάθη γίνονται και προκλήσεις αντιμετωποίζουμε και ετσαονόμαστε με κόσμο και συζητάμε
με κόσμο και έχουμε διαφωνίες και είναι θεμητών αυτό είναι ένα χώροστεράστιος έχουμε να κάπουμε
πάρα πολύ κόσμο μην ξεχναται ότι όλοη πιστεύουν πως είναι ιδική είτε εινεγωνίσειτείναι παπούδες ιαγιά
δεσμαθητές φιτητές παρόλα αυτά ναι επιστεύω ότι τω να γνωρίζεις αυτό το χώρο να πό
μέσα είναι τελικά πλέον έκτημα και δεν είναι όμως το μόνο δηλαδή τω α γνωρίζεις
και να σετεχνοκράτης να ίσουν τεχνοκράτησ είναι θετικό σε συνδιασμό μετα προσωπικά χαρακτηριστικά του άλλο
τω ναδιαλέγουμε των ακούο των να πιστεύω πραγματικά ότι έχω να μάθω από τους άλλους
και αυτά που έχομάθει περισότερα ενα περισσότερο είναι από τα ίδια τα παιδιά πρέπει να
πό εκείνη είναι μεγαλύτερή μου δάσκαλη αυτό νομίζω όπως με βοή θα πάρα πολύ να
προχωρώ και σίγουρα ι στήριξη η πολιτική στήριξη των ακολουθώ ευγιακριμένο πρόγραμμα δεν κάνω ότι
θέλω κάνω τοσωστόν κατά τηγνώμημου και το ότι δεν υπήρξα πολιτικός πάλι πεζηρόλων αυτό ότι
είμαι εδώ για να δουλέψουν να προσφέρωυς αυτόν το χώρο των οποίο αγαπώ και οποίος
είναι ι ζωή μολοκληρι η μεγαλύτερη δυσκολία της να θυνάς μη χαηλίδοου στων ενάμι συγχρόνο
παντιμετωπσες στηπουργίο παιδίαπια ήτα πολύ δυσκολιερώτηση δεν είναι οι άνθρωποι δεν είναι οι συνεργασίες μου
η μεγαλύτερη δυσκολία είναι να αντιμετωπίσεις ανθρώπους που θα έπρεπε να γνωρίζουν και να είναι
διαβασμένοι και δεν είναι σε διάφορα από στα αυτό σημαίνει οι συνεργάτες μας από όλους
τους χώρους οι οποίοι πρέπει πρότα να να ενημερωμένοι σωστά και μετά να τοποθετούνται για
να λαμβάνουν και αποφάσεις υτό μπορεί να σημαίνει η κόμματα μπορεί να σημαίνειβους